okay thanks a lot for the introduction
and i'm going to talk about the
blockchain and cryptocurrencies
including the good the evil and life and
the universe and
to cryptographers in this room the
composable universe
and and everything so this will cover a
couple
of recent and ongoing works uh joined
with my students
uh ahmed khalsa andrew miller the taiwan
and with my colleagues
on ari juice and uh is pepperminto
okay and here's the plan
and i'm going to first introduce what is
the blockchain model of secure
computation and i will try to explain it
in a cryptographer's language and then
later in the talk i'll talk about
um how to design protocols in this
blockchain model of secure computation
there has been a long line of research
on
cryptographic currency and and
in this talk i'm going to specifically
focus on decentralized cryptocurrency
and the first popular embodiment of a
decentralized cryptocurrency as we all
know is bitcoin
okay and this also popularized the
concept of a blockchain
and what is a blockchain in layman's
terms in bitcoin
and as we all know there's the mining
process
there's a network of distributed miners
and the miners
solve computational puzzles and as a
result
they reach consensus about
the end state of the global ledger and
and roughly speaking every ten minutes
a new block will be mined which includes
and
new transactions that have entered the
system
okay this talk is not going to be about
bitcoin specifics
but rather i like you to think of the
blockchain in a conceptual manner
so conceptually what is the blockchain
the blockchain
as we all know starts data and in the
case of bitcoin the data is essentially
a global ledger
and the blockchain performs computation
and in the case
of bitcoin this computation is
transaction verification
okay and as we all know both the data
and the computation are decentralized
and essentially the network is reaching
consensus
about the both the data and the
computation and
and also the computation will determine
the most
up-to-date state of the data
and in the most recent eurocrypt korea
and others
showed the security of the bitcoin
backbone protocol
under the assumption that the majority
of hash power in the system will behave
honestly
okay so in specifically they show that
the protocol will reach consensus and
moreover some life
liveness property will be satisfied uh
and actually aguilos will be giving a
talk on wednesday about this subject
so therefore this talk and will not
focus on
the secure consensus protocol design but
rather as a starting point
i will assume that a secure consensus
protocol exists
and and let's think about you know what
we can do
with such a secure blockchain
okay so when we think about the
consensus protocol of course we need to
think of the
um bitcoin network as being distributed
but when we actually use the blockchain
to design protocols
it will be better if we think of the
blockchain as a single conceptual entity
and in specifically uh here's an
important observation this blockchain
entity can be trusted for correctness
but it cannot be trusted for privacy
correctness because you know the
when the network appears reach consensus
they will agree on
the correct result of the computation
but as for privacy as we all know
everything that you start on the
blockchain is exposed to the public
okay and let me reinterpret the
statement using
universal composable terminology okay
and the way to think of a blockchain is
to think of it as a cryptographic
functionality so in the uc model we have
parties and we have functionalities
and here we can think of f blockchain as
being a functionality
but in comparison with an ideal
functionalities in the mpc literature
as we know like a standard npc ideal
functionalities preserve
will preserve both privacy and
correctness but here
this functionality actually will expose
all of its internal states
to everyone
okay any questions so therefore when we
talk about the blockchain model of
secure computation
we are effectively designing protocols
in the f blockchain hybrid world
and let me give you a concrete example
so here's a way to think of bitcoin
okay i claim this is an not very precise
as i will mention later but one way to
think about um
bitcoin is that it realizes a f
bitcoin functionality and that's
essentially a global ledger
and when parties send a transfer command
to the functionality the functionality
will
in this case and the sender is s and the
recipient is r
and the functionality of course notifies
the adversary of the event
and then it will check if s has indeed
has
this amount of money uh in its balance
and if so it will make the transfer by
updating
this global ledger so so in in reality
bitcoin actually doesn't implement this
ideal functionality this is like a
an overly simple simplified version
um but but for the purpose of this talk
it helps to think of bitcoin
in this simplified manner
okay
so given this as we can see this is a
very simple blockchain functionality
and the obvious question is what else
can we do with the blockchain
functionality
so let's liberate ourselves and think
about what more things we can do
okay and with this i'm going to
mention that so ethereum is going to be
a new cryptocurrency that will be
launched soon
and the main idea behind ethereum is to
support
uh what's called um programmable smart
contracts
so now many of you may have heard of
ethereum and heard of unprogrammable
smart contracts
okay and i've also been asked to explain
smart contracts to
various people and here's a way to kind
of explain it to cryptographers
so the layman's way to explain smart
contracts
and ethereum is that ethereum
effectively
offers a touring complete language on
top of
something like bitcoin so as we all know
bitcoin doesn't have a touring complete
scripting language but in the
cryptographer's terminology
essentially we can think of ethereum as
offering this functionality
we still have a ledger like in the case
of bitcoin
um but f ethereum is also parameterized
by a set of user defined contracts
and these contracts can you know have ma
they are kind of standard
turing machines they have memory they
can do computation and these
contracts can basically talk to this
global ledger
and and also like i said this
functionality would
expose all of its internal states to any
party that queries the functionality yes
do the smart contracts have access to
external sources of information like you
know you can price of a stock on the
stock market or things like that and
yes you can think of and so this
contract can receive input from
any party including let's say a stock
exchange can provide inputs to the
contract as well
so basically the stock exchange can be a
party in your system as well
there's a way to make sure that
everybody agrees what this
price was on a given day and things like
that and so for instance if your
contract depends
on the stock price then one way is you
can hard code the public key of the
stock
exchange in er smart contract program
and if i'm
interacting with the contract it's
implicit consent that i agree
to the programmable logic of this
contract including agreeing on
who should be the party that has the say
on the stock price
yes yes i will give an example later
yes these contracts that have persistent
storage outside of the global ledger
um the contracts and
the storage are instantiated on the
on the network of miners so every miner
will start the state
corresponding to the contracts but the
protocol itself the participants can
have local
storage right it's kind of like like i
said protocols in this model
and are basically protocols in this f
ethereum hybrid world
so every party in the protocol can have
its own
local storage that's not part of the
storage of the contract
the contract is basically this ideal
functionality and
this functionality storage is basically
stopped by every miner
in the system so the contract there's no
consensus on the
storage for the contracts the network of
miners will reach consensus on the
states of this functionality so all the
states will be
have consensus including
yes yes including the storage here yeah
if you think of this as a program these
are just like functions or modules in
the program
so so this big program has storage
corresponding to the program
that's part of the consensus
yes yes it is like basically the
consensus is for this whole
functionality including the code
and yes in basically
what happens is in every epoch
the miners will run this big
functionality including other
user-defined contracts in the system and
update
the global states and you can think of
the state as being partitioned
across these contracts so every contract
has its own state
but they for instance all these
contracts will share a global ledger
okay
okay before i give an example ethereum
is going to and launch very soon and in
fact
there have been several planned
pre-releases and that are going on right
now
okay so there are a lot of details that
have been hiding
i talked about this global ledger but
for instance i haven't talked about time
i haven't talked about pseudonymity
and i haven't talked about how to model
front-running attacks
time is very important because if you
think about the blockchain it advances
in block intervals
so there's a natural notion of time and
it turns out time is important for
defining
for designing protocols with financial
fairness in the system because
if parties apart the aborts can be made
evident by time outs and then you can
financially penalize the parties that
are part in the system
okay pseudonymity is also important
because in this framework every party
can make up
an arbitrary number of public keys or
pseudonyms and then they can basically
act
um based on these pseudonyms and these
pseudonyms cannot be linked
to their real identities and in the
standard uc model like
there isn't this notion of pseudonymity
so you have to explicitly model that in
your framework
okay so in our work basically we think
it will be helpful to have
like a uc-like model for the blockchain
model of secure computation and our
approach is to basically
use a wrapper based system where we
model these
things explicitly in the wrapper so when
you write
your user-defined portion of the
functionality you don't have to worry
about these common elements
so this notational system is designed to
be kind of user-friendly
by factoring out these common and often
tedious
modeling facts
okay i wanted to quickly mention some
earlier works that and effectively we're
designing protocols in this blockchain
model of secure computation without
explicitly stating this fact for
instance
and this paper designed a secure lottery
protocol over bitcoin
and i guess they don't have a formal
security proof
or security model and then zero cash is
another example for instance
uh i'll mention more about zero cash's
security model later
and and there are also these very
nice works by benthoff and
kumarensen and also this one
and then these two papers have um
some degree of modeling but the model is
not exactly so general to cover
and programmable smart contracts
okay so it would actually be very handy
to have a unified modeling framework
to define security of protocols in this
model and to also for
formally reasoning about the security of
protocols in the blockchain model of
secure computation
so that's what we do and it turns out
that there's also some non-trivial
challenges that we encounter when doing
the modeling for instance
we realized that in order for the models
to be usable
and we'd like to have certain
composition theorems that are actually
not covered by
uc guc or gnusi so so my student andrew
miller is actually working
working on extending augmenting and
these models like ucg uc
new c to and have the compass new
composition theorems that we want
okay okay
so i would like to talk about a cool
system that we are building right now
and the system is called hak for for
example in this picture this is the hawk
and this is the serpent and as we all
know the ethereum's programming language
is called serpent
and and um so hack will provide
privacy preserving smart contracts and
let me
motivate this and as i do this i will
give you an example
of a smart contract so this is one of
the canonical examples
an auction contract in this auction
contract
and this contract will receive bids from
parties
and whenever it receives a bid it will
check if the party indeed has
this amount of money in its balance and
if so it will deduct the uh
the bid from this party's balance
so effectively at this point the
contract is the contract
is withholding this amount of money on
behalf of this party
okay and whenever let's say there's an
auctioneer and whenever the auctioneer
says close
to close the auction and the contract
will basically
decide who is the highest bidder and the
highest the
bidder will be the winner and he will
pay the second highest
price okay and then
the contract will basically update the
ledger accordingly based on the result
of the computation
and here so this contract can easily be
implemented on top of ethereum but
there's one big problem
and one of the big elephants
in the room is privacy so here as we can
see
the bits are visible to the public
and and in something like a second price
auction
what you really want is that the users
should not be able to see each other's
bids
until they submit their own bits because
otherwise the
auction can be subject to certain
manipulations
okay so that's one example
and here is another interesting example
so this code snippet is part of
resembles part of a contract that my
undergraduate students wrote
for a smart contract programming lab
okay
and here and the contract is very simple
the two players are playing rock paper
scissors
and they each send their input tries to
the contract you know rock
paper or scissors and then the contract
decides the winner
and gives um the uh
the bets to the winner so this is the
part of the contract where the parties
are sending inputs
and of course the the problem here is
that the inputs are visible to everyone
so if i'm smart i'm going to wait for
you to send your input and then decide
what should be my own input
okay
okay so it seems like with something
like ethereum
and there isn't an an easy way to
achieve
privacy unchained and all of your
financial transactions will be exposed
to the public
and also the pseudonymity guarantees of
these
decentralized cryptocurrencies they are
simply not strong enough because in many
cases for instance in our sealed bid
option it's not enough just to be
pseudonymous you also want to hide the
details of the financial transaction
like
how much money is being exchanged
and also maybe for instance in in like
financial swaps
and privacy can also be very important
so in hak
we we allow non-specialist programmers
to
write contracts so to write contracts in
hawk you don't have to be a
cryptographer
basically we will compile your program
into a privacy preserving protocol
and that can run on top of a
decentralized
blockchain system okay
so let me kind of very quickly explain
how the protocol works
i'll keep it very brief so the idea is
that
and in the beginning the parties will
commit their inputs and and their in
this case the values
we can think of the values as the
parties bits
so they commit these to the blockchain
and and one thing to note is that
the money commitment is not an ordinary
commitment
it's like a cryptographically fancy
commitment
okay because because because there are
some special constraints on money like
money needs to be conserved money cannot
be created
and therefore these commitments needs to
be uh some cryptographically fancy
commitment
okay and then in the second and so in
the second stage
it's called the compute stage um the
parties
will um encrypt their inputs and
value to the manager's public key so
essentially the parties are opening
their commitments to the manager
and they also attach a zero knowledge
proof to show that the competition is
done correctly
okay now the manager can see all of the
parties inputs and bids
and and he can perform the competition
on behalf of other parties
and then he will compute and these are
kind of
um privacy preserving coins so he will
compute these outputs
and and then he will encrypt outputs to
each party's public key
so this output output output i
is necessary for party i to later
spend this private coin okay and then
of course this manager will attach as
your knowledge proof to show that
all this competition is done correctly
okay um
so one thing that i want to mention is
that this music
and proofs proves
two main things one when that one is
that the payout distribution
is correctly computed from this
this contract program and in this case
the contract program is our auction
program
and secondly and this zero knowledge
proof needs to show that the money is
conserved
in the sense that all the input coins
must equal to the the sum of the input
coins must be equal to the sum of the
output kinds
okay so in this sense uh we can preserve
the security of the
currency because we don't want money to
be created out of thin
air and so on and so forth okay so this
is a
very very simplified version of our real
protocol
um it is important to note that this
auctioneer
is only minimally trusted in the sense
that it is not trusted for correctness
because the every competition the this
manager or auctioneer does
has nisiks to vouch for its correctness
it is not trusted for input independence
and what do i mean by input independence
in the case of auction
it means that users should not see other
users bids
before submitting their on submitting
their own bids
so even if the manager colludes with
um parties in the system he cannot
disclose bids
to the other parties before all parties
commit to their bids
and and also importantly the manager is
not trusted for the security of the
currency
like for instance the manager cannot
create money out of thing air
and and finally so so basically this
manager is only trusted for
posterior privacy and within this
the scope of this contract like if you
have other contract instances running in
your system
and these other contract instances don't
have to trust
and this yarn manager
okay and so the reason why we introduced
this manager is
mostly for efficiency because it's also
easy to implement this manager just with
generic mpc but we didn't do that
because this would
not be very practical and it would
actually be very
attractive to implement this manager
using something like sgx
okay and so i'll leave it at that
and i'm going to quickly flash over
flash some of the contracts we have
ah sjx is intel's new processor
and they have uh this sjx security
extension
and and and basically uh you can think
of it
and so if you have heard about things
like trusted computing tpms
sjx is supposed to uh provide
similar security properties um but but
with stronger guarantees and it's also
much more efficient than uh something
like um
tpms and yeah
yeah basically it will provide things
like um encryption
authentication of memory attestation of
the computation
uh and so on so forth basically you can
preserve
you can think of it as a ideal
functionality
in crypto a crypto trusted third party
okay so this is just to flash some of
the contracts we have composed
with hack and this is sealed bit option
like rock paper scissors kickstarter
like a crowd fundraising and financial
swap
and this is a picture my student made
for the compiler i'm not going to
explain it in detail but it's a pretty
picture
we have implemented a preliminary
prototype and the performance numbers
you see are not going to be the end
performance numbers because there are a
lot of optimizations that we wanted to
make but we haven't had time to make yet
so right now with 100 users if we
implement a 100 user auction of crowd
fundraising and the auctioneer runs
the most expensive part is the snack
proof
and the auctioneer takes about 2.7
minutes to run it's not proof and each
user takes about 50 seconds
and and for the users costs it's
actually independent of the number of
users
in the system okay
i'm going to say a few final words about
hack and
draw some relations to upcoming talks
and then i'm going to quickly end
one one thing that i neglected to
mention is that hawk
supports financial fairness in the sense
that if parties apart
from the protocol they will be
financially penalized including the
manager
i won't go into the details because
actually ranjit is going to give a talk
on wednesday about
the topic of fairness and and i'd like
to point out that their results can
essentially be reformulated in our
uc and blockchain uc model and these
results can be restated
okay and the second thing like i said
our protocol
relies on zero knowledge snarks
and one key insight is that on-chain
computation is very expensive because
on-chain computation
is done by all miners and in reality you
also have to
pay transaction fees for the unchained
computation and that's why snacks can be
desirable
for designing protocols in this
blockchain model in the sense that
you can do snack verification on chain
which is constant cost
and then you try to factor most of the
computation away from the blockchain
i will leave michael leave it to michael
rawfish and aaron trelmer to talk about
snacks on wednesday
aaron is also going to talk about zero
cash which also
builds on top of and snarks and i like
to mention that huck is
strictly more general than zero cash
and it's likely more secure and so when
i say strictly more general
uh basically zero cash is a privacy
preserving
cryptocurrency but they only allow
direct transfer of money between users
so you can roughly speak and think of
zero cash as real
realizing the private version of the
bitcoin global ledger functionality but
that's not a precise statement um but
whereas in hack we support
four programmability so zero cache
doesn't support any programmability
and zero cache has an
indistinguishability
based security notion and their security
definition seems to
not preclude certain leakages and so
it our protocols are proven secure under
our blockchain model
of secure computation this doesn't mean
that zero cash's protocol is necessarily
insecure it just means that
there's no obvious way to prove their
protocol secure under a desirable
and simulation-based security notion
okay
and i wanted to cover this but it seems
like i won't have time so i would just
make a very quick announcement and these
smart contract systems can be used for
good
but they can also be used by the bad
guys
to conduct crime okay so in the recent
so basically bitcoin has already
stimulated a lot of crime activities
and the high level message is that smart
contract can make it worse
okay i i won't have time to actually
cover any of the details because i think
going over the time is a crime yes
that's a crime too
but i would like just to quickly mention
like we have device
and criminal contracts for things like
document leakage site defacement
assassination and also key theft it
turns out
that there needs to be some non-trivial
techniques
in designing this criminal smart
contracts and our paper basically talks
about
these and techniques and part of the
exercise
and this is not an encouragement for you
to conduct crime but
rather we would like to raise awareness
about how technology can be potentially
be misused
okay
yeah it would be very interesting to
think about how to like basically deploy
these technologies in a way that
and can help law enforcement to defend
against such crime crime activities
okay and so finally uh i like to say
cryptocurrency is very cool and deserves
academic attention
and one thing that's really fascinating
about cryptocurrency is that it brings
together all these different disciplines
i talked about crypto i touched just a
little bit on programming languages but
then there are all these other things
like economics game theory mechanism
design
which i didn't have time to cover so i
strongly encourage you to go to andrew
miller's talk on thursday and he will
give
an uh an overview of the research
perspectives and open research problems
related to cryptocurrency finally i'm
excited to announce that
we are actually establishing a new
initiative
and joined between cornell cornell tech
and berkeley it's called
ic3 initiative on cyber currencies and
contracts so this will basically help to
foster
collaborations between academic research
and
real world financial institutions and
startup companies
we have postdoc positions available in
programming languages crypto
security and distributed systems
anything that's related to the
to cryptocurrency okay thank you very
much